quand on parle des événements de mai 68
aujourd'hui il ya un mythe qui s'est
constitué il ya un mythe surtout un sur
la commune de paris je vois qu'on fait
aujourd'hui il ya un mythe genre sur
napoléon il ya un mythe
enfin bref pour ça que je ne suis pas
content tu lui dis qu'il faut
déconstruire l'histoire entre nous
puisque c'est c'est un fait une
polémique vous faut déconstruire un
certain récit historique qui ne
correspond à aucune réalité
or mai 68 on a quand même oublier ce
petit détail tout petit détail c'est que
ça se solde par la plus grande victoire
de la droite de l'histoire de la
république peut depuis peu on va
peut-être avoir pire d'enfin non mais la
grande marée de droite à la fin donc
quand vous lisez les récits je n'ai pas
l'impression vous l'impression que c'est
un grand mouvement unanime de révolte de
la jeunesse du peuple etc
donc voilà la révolution annoncée ça
débouche sur un littoral à droite donc
ça mais en même temps tous et l'extrême
gauche dans dans la contestation
quittions pousser la contestation
une grande partie des gens que je
connaissais tu sais où joue dont j'ai
fait connaissance
je les ai retrouvés plus tard et
beaucoup les plus talentueux il est et
où il était devenu publicitaires au
service des grands multinationales
capitalistes ils étaient très efficaces
parce qu'ils mettaient tout leur talent
inventive au service des capitalismes
qu'il servait avec le avec justement
beaucoup d'imagination
c'est évident qu'un espèces dutra
libéralisme de butô excusez-moi d'ultra
libertarisme il ya un ultra libertarisme
qui c'est qu'a basculé dans un ultra
libéralisme qui conspuent qui
contribuent à cette étrangeté que
finalement va d'abord c'est giscard qui
a été lue après c'est pas c'est jusqu'à
que çà çà çà sans doute contribué à
à muscler le néolibéralisme
[Musique]